this is my cat rubix one of the many
amazing things about rubix is that he
naturally works to keep himself clean
his barbed tongue is really good at
getting rid of the dust and dirt that he
gets at his fur every day
but sometimes he needs a little help
getting clean
healthy lakes and rivers are kind of
like cats they naturally clean
themselves
they have lots of spaces where
contaminants from water can settle and
to be filtered out by the soil and
organisms like plants the clean water
produced by these systems is important
for irrigation drinking water and the
ecosystem but when humans add sewage and
storm water pollution into rivers too
quickly natural ponds and streams can't
keep up
the pollution can then build up and
become a danger to wildlife and people
to prevent this from happening many
urban areas in developed countries use
water management systems to treat their
water waste
let's say i'm giving rubik's a bath one
day when i unplug the drain where will
the water go first it will travel
through a long network of sewer pipes
where it will be joined by water waste
from homes and businesses
and maybe some storm water from catch
basins along roads eventually it will
reach the water treatment plant where it
will go under primary sewage treatment
primary sewage treatment which is also
called physical sewage treatment is
where the treatment plant physically
takes out large objects from the water
this prevents the objects from clogging
up the pipes and pumps in future
treatment steps
during primary treatment the water goes
through a series of screens with
progressively smaller and smaller
openings
the screens sift out objects like sticks
rocks rags plastic bottles and rubik's
hair
even though the screens take out many of
the larger objects there's still a lot
of grit in the water afterwards grit is
made up of small loose particles of sand
gravel coffee grounds food waste and
other pieces of material to get rid of
the grit the treatment plant pumps the
water through long narrow tanks that
slow down the flow enough that the grit
has time to settle to the bottom all
that thick soft mud that gathers at the
bottom of the grit tank is called sludge
and it's collected and treated the water
then moves on to secondary or biological
treatment
during this stage the wastewater is
aerated or mixed with air to create
perfect conditions to help increase the
population of aerobic bacteria aerobic
bacteria are important because they
quickly feed on and break down the
organic waste in the water sometimes
bacteria loaded sludge called activated
sludge is also added to help grow even
more bacteria
when the bacteria have plenty of oxygen
they metabolize the organic material
into carbon dioxide and yes more sludge
the sludge again settles to the bottom
of the tank and is collected for
treatment i like to think of secondary
treatment as kind of like being a good
caretaker to millions of microbial pets
when we provide our microscopic pets
with oxygen and food then they help us
out by doing the cleaning work that's
why secondary treatment is also called
biological treatment because it uses
living organisms
like primary treatment secondary
treatment generates lots of sludge some
of the sludge may be recycled and added
to water entering secondary treatment
this increases the population of aerobic
bacteria in the wastewater so the
bacteria remove the organic waste faster
the sludge collected from primary and
secondary treatment can be dried and
buried as a waste product or dehydrated
and heated to make a soil-like material
called biosolids that can be used in
agriculture by the time the primary and
secondary treatment steps are completed
about 85 percent of the organic
pollution has been removed from the
wastewater but there are still some
disease-causing bacteria and viruses
that are present in the water
so most treatment plants add another
step to secondary treatment disinfection
some treatment plants may use
ultraviolet light treatment to prevent
disease-carrying bacteria from being
able to multiply or treatment may use
chlorine or ozone treatment processes to
kill bacteria and viruses
chlorination will kill more than 99 of
the harmful bacteria
in some places the wastewater treatment
plant directly releases cleaned water
into drinking water sources agricultural
water sources or recreational water
bodies
in these cases the water may go through
yet another treatment process called
tertiary treatment or advanced treatment
tertiary treatment looks different at
different water treatment plants
sometimes it uses a more targeted
approach to the removal of specific
wastewater components
some examples include additional
biological treatments capable of
removing nitrogen and phosphorus or
physical chemical separation techniques
such as filtration carbon adsorption
distillation and reverse osmosis for
removing a variety of chemicals despite
being effective these techniques are
expensive and not widely used
after treatment the newly cleaned water
will go out into the world perhaps to an
ocean or to a river or maybe even into
rubik's next bath